when we think of religion in the Middle
East we tend to view it in a rather
simplified and generalizing way in the
Middle East people are Muslim basically
and while yes there are of course a lot
of Muslims in the Middle East there is a
whole host of other religious minorities
that have lived there historically and
today and not just jews and christians
and one of those less known religious
minority groups are known as the
mandaeans man bei ism can be described
as a monotheistic religion with strong
dualistic tendencies similar to other
movements like Gnosticism it shares a
lot of elements with other religions
like Judaism Christianity and so Astron
ISM but of course constitutes its own
unique tradition and religion the word
monday ism or Monday ins comes from the
word manda or Monday which means
knowledge in the old language called
Monday in a Semitic language that only
survives today through the Liturgy of
the Monday and priests in Arabic and
Muslim context they have also often been
known as Suba which basically means
those who baptized this also connects it
to the term sabaeans which is a
mysterious religious group mentioned in
the Quran alongside Christianity and
Judaism as the people of the book some
historically and today have therefore
concluded that the sabaeans in the Quran
are in fact the mandaeans
the mundanes have for most of history
been confined or located in the southern
regions of Iraq along the Euphrates and
Tigris Rivers but their actual
geographic origins are rather uncertain
and unknown many believe that they
originates in in Palestine in the first
three centuries ad and maybe in
connection to certain Jewish groups
along the Jordan River that put a heavy
emphasis on the practice of baptism as a
ritual practice now this of course sort
of very much connects them to movements
like the Essenes and with John the
Baptist in fact John the Baptist who
very famously baptized Jesus in the New
Testament plays a very central role to
the Mende and religion he isn't
considered a founder by any means but he
has every central role as a kind of
prophet and one of the
main sort of propagators interestingly
while they share many aspects and
mythological backgrounds of the
Abrahamic faiths they attended to have a
different perspective on it a lot of the
time Adam the first man that God created
is venerated and Monday ISM is
considered to have originated with him
so similar to for example dis LOM they
thus view themselves as the true
original religion of mankind and all
other religions as sort of deviations
from this original religion they also
venerate Adams son Seth and one of
Noah's sons Shem as transmitters of the
Mende and faith but this also means that
all other biblical prophets mentioned in
the Old Testaments aside from these few
are considered false similarly while
they may affirm that John the Baptist
did baptize Jesus they consider the
Christian faith to be false and Jesus as
a kind of heretic and misleader
who deviated from John's true religion
we should always avoid thinking about
religions as or through a kind of
Christian framework as having a founder
and a sacred scripture for example but
there are a few texts that sort of
contain a lot of these basic monday and
teachings the most prominent of these
can be said to be a book called guinness
Arriba or a simply ginza which is a
collection of theological historical and
ritual teachings there is also the
mandiant book of john which is thought
to have been authored by John the
Baptist himself and contains stories
about his life and teachings and many
other scriptures of varying sorts as
well scholars disagree on when these
texts were written or compiled some
placing them or at least a few of them
after the coming of Islam in these 7th
century and others placed them a couple
of centuries before that now if we were
to talk about the beliefs or a theology
or cosmology of this religion we need to
make some things clear first like with
many other religions there isn't one
clear story or agreed-upon version of
the cosmological beliefs often with
religions that don't share the sort of
institutionalized structure of a
Catholic Church for example there isn't
the same emphasis put on orthodoxy or a
certain orthodoxy that has been sort of
preserved as historian of religions
Jordan
Jacobson Buckley points out quote the
sheer mass of variations in the creation
mythology makes it impossible to appoint
one specific version as the original and
quote in any case the basic common
elements of the religious beliefs are as
I said earlier strongly dualistic with a
huge emphasis on light versus darkness
purity verses on cleanliness and so on
they are a monotheistic faith as they
believe in one Almighty transcendent God
which they call higher MB and the
highest sort of part of the cosmos a
pure world of lights in which this God
resides is also home to other sort of
spiritual luminous beings and the most
important of these is a spirit that they
refer to as manda and hai which means
knowledge of life and is it is
particularly through with this spiritual
being or similar to an angel almost it
is through this being that the Mende in
teachings and religions the religion has
been conveyed throughout history to
different prophets like Seth or to John
the Baptist there is then a kind of
hierarchy of existence from this highest
pure world of lights right down to the
lowest sort of dark bowels of creation
were evil and sort of darkness rule and
in between these two extremes the
material world of human existence exists
or is situated and contains elements of
both of these extremes according to some
scholars Monday ISM is here rather
similar to Gnosticism as it views the
human material body as created by a kind
of Demiurge through the powers of evil
the material body is therefore seen as a
kind of prison of the soul and the souls
goal in life is to escape this body
after death and make its way to the
higher world of pure and light but how
is this achieved well this brings us of
course to the practices of this religion
as I mentioned there is no orthodoxy in
Monday ISM this is actually a good
example to show that for the most part
religions are usually something that we
do rather than something we believe the
Chiefs of the Mandaeans are strongly
varied but the ritual practices are
pretty consistent throughout we could
therefore classify Monday ISM primarily
as a religion of orthopraxy those rights
practice rather than orthodoxy right
belief in this cosmological scheme that
I just described water is the only thing
in the material world that is entirely
pure through water one can remove sin
and uncleanliness and give the soul like
kind of rebirth similar to Christian and
early Jewish ideas this is why the
ritual of baptism called mascoutah is
perhaps the most central practice in
Monday ISM contrary to Christianity
where one is baptized only once the
Monday ins traditionally are baptized
once every week on Sundays one is to be
baptized in running water
traditionally usually one of the two
rivers in Iraq and this has created some
problems for a few diaspora communities
today through baptism the soul is
purified which will help it in its
journey to the world of lights after
death the baptism is performed by a
class of priests and usually in a place
of worship called a Mandi I'm sort of
usually placed beside the river a second
important ritual is called meseta a kind
of ascension of the soul ceremony this
can take many different forms but is
primarily performed to help departed
souls on the journey to the world of
lights which is plagued by demons and
other nasty things mandaeans also pray
daily but the number of prayers can vary
everything from three to five or seven
times a day as you might expect also the
idea of purity and cleanliness is very
important to the religion and mandaeans
have been in are still rather strict
about not allowing anyone to marry
outside of the religion they have also
traditionally not allowed people to
convert to mundane ism which has partly
led to its sort of decline in numbers
other ethical ideas and practices
include a kind of pacifism mandaeans
aren't allowed to carry any weapons for
example and giving to charity and also a
ritual fast at last for 36 days the
Mandaeans have always basically been a
minority in this region which hasn't
been ruled by many empires and
kingdoms throughout history and as usual
with minority groups this means they
haven't always been treated all that
well they were persecuted and oppressed
under the sustain ian's Persian Empire
before the arrival of the Arabs and
Islamic sort of conquerors as I
mentioned earlier because of their
identification with the sabaeans in the
Quran they have usually been identified
with the people of the book and thus
have retained certain rights and freedom
of religion and you could say sort of a
certain level of autonomy throughout the
Muslim period but of course this doesn't
mean that they weren't persecuted from
time to time by the Muslim rulers as
well in no period has this been more
prominent perhaps than in the last
century or so with the increasing
instability in the Middle East both
politically and in terms of rising
religious fundamentalism during the rule
of the Baath Party of Saddam Hussein and
Iraq and especially after his execution
and the war in 2003 the Mende ins were
given such a hard time that the majority
have by now emigrated to regions outside
of the Middle East it's estimated that
around 80 percents of mandarins live in
diaspora communities around the world
which is a rather recent development
this is that the certain conflicts
within the community regarding things
like integration and how much the
religious practices and beliefs can be
modified according to new contexts in a
place in like Sweden for example which
is rather cold for maybe one half of the
year and in which even the waters
outside can freeze this of course
creates problems regarding how to gain
access to running water for the the
baptism rituals and this has led to some
internal conflicts were some allow
compromises like indoor pools while
others don't want to make this
compromise similarly intermarriage with
other religious groups have been heated
discussions as has been the question of
people are allowed to convert the
mundane religion is also strongly
connected to ethnicity much like
religions like the Yazidi store to some
degree Judaism as well and your identity
as a mundane is primarily determined by
your parents being mandiant and so this
is the reason why conversion has usually
been neglected it's hard to say how many
Monday ins exist in the world today but
estimates place them everywhere between
forty thousand to a hundred thousand
people with as I said eighty percent of
them living outside of the Middle East
today so what do you think have you ever
heard of Monday ISM and what are your
thoughts on this fascinating religion
let's discuss in the comments and if you
want to support the channel you can like
the video and subscribe I'll see you
next time
[Music]
you